here in this video we will take a look
at a brand new xenomorph that is totally
badass in both looks and overall
features firstly these are the classic
alien monsters which were seen first in
the alien movies of the 70s and 80s
they have a very interesting life cycle
and are very complex weapons of death
their appearances vary differently
depending on the different hosts into
which the embryo is inserted in a cinema
of physical form varies greatly based on
its life stage height caste age and host
there is usually the queen and the
drones and sometimes specialized ones
like the praetorian and the warriors but
the alpha is something entirely
different so with that intro let's take
a deeper look into this new beast
the alpha is a product of the cinema of
publication rights being bought by
marvel which means that disney which is
the owner of marvel merged 20th century
fox into its foe the original plan is
for them to produce comics and maybe
later on movies as well marvel's new
alien comics will take place within a
separate continuity with the publisher
also set to reprint classic alien comics
which were originally published by dark
horse so this year we got to see the new
alien comics and boy oh boy they were
fun to read and they brought with them a
connection to the original alien
storyline as well as new origin stories
to these fantastic creatures which we
will dive into in another video
so in the comics the alpha was a massive
hawking xenomorph with the appearance of
praetorian its dna was derived from both
human and the cochrane highland goat's
dna as seen by his huge curved headcrust
which was derived from the goat's horns
the alpha was one of a kind it was born
on epsilon station after weyland yutani
defense agent gabriel cruz and his unit
were apprehended by xenomorphs gabriel
was impregnated and later the alpha was
retrieved as a chest burster it had one
mission and that is to get back to its
host that survived it and his son which
also has another alpha xenomorph embryo
inside of him with hints of an enhanced
psychic connection to both of them
now let's take a deeper look at this
alien and try to come up with a
description the alpha first of all is
bigger than most other xenomorphs with
the exception of the queen the empress
and the king but it did act like the de
facto leader of the xenomorphs in the
epsilon station and it was
hyper-intelligent kinda like the
indominus rex from jurassic world while
the normal drones were around seven feet
tall this one stood twice their height
so around 14 feet
it has similar biomechanical exoskeleton
as the rest of the species but it seems
to be bulkier and more heavily armoured
especially with its head which has four
big horns and a curved plate or a crest
which resembles a triceratops dinosaur
moreover its tail is also longer and
appears to be more prehensile than the
rest
so what are its powers or special
abilities if it has any well this lethal
alien species dubbed the alpha is
capable of immense chaos and destruction
and possibly carrying the ability to
coordinate the efforts of the entire
standard xenomorphs in its group while
the adult xenomorph is a living weapon
noted for their ferocity and deadliness
in any condition the alpha is on another
level
being a global threat normal ones once
fully matured have great physical
strength and agility and they are
masters of stealth same traits that the
alpha has as well it is also very
durable and can withstand weapon fire
and even function a hundred percent with
wounds on his body and also yes it is
safe to say that it has the deadly
acidic blood
okay now let's see where it ranks when
compared against the other xenomorphs
since these aliens are an alien swarm
slash hive species they need a proper
line of command in order to execute
orders otherwise they would just lie
dormant and hibernate until the
unfortunate happens to cross their parts
so
in the marvel comics we have not seen a
queen yet we did see a woman in dark or
also called the goddess which might be
the penultimate form of a xenomorph or
the creator of them like how the dark
god null is to the symbiotes so the
alpha even though it is on the top of
the pecking order alongside maybe
praetorians in that list it is still a
drone but with special connections to
the goddess instead of the queen
so there you have it guys the alpha
xenomorph from marvel alien comics which
were released this year hope you have
enjoyed watching this video and also do
tell us what you think about the alien
goddess which is kind of like the queen
of queens anyway with that we come to
the end of the video so do hit that like
button for support and subscribe as well
to be a part of the mind cue family but
most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam